mr secretary was it a success
a thumbs up from america's secretary of
state and two from the prime minister
for the first in-person international
meeting since the pandemic began
but was this all premature has this been
held too soon prime minister
the day didn't start so well india's
foreign minister had come halfway around
the world
only to be stuck in his hotel room
self-isolating with his entire
delegation
after two of its officials tested
positive for coronavirus
by day's end the foreign secretary was
having to defend the decision
to hold this meeting face to face
immediately that we
saw those tests they were in twice into
self-isolation
the diplomatic exemption has been going
on right the way through the pandemic
but it's been with the additional
measures that we've put in place
and actually they work very effectively
to isolate any
conceivable potential risk in this case
my suggestion is that we get cracking
in two pack days the meeting did deliver
diplomatically
culminating in a lengthy final
communique the g7 member states
expressed concern
on china's human rights abuses in
xinjiang and tibet
warned russia against malign activities
and cyber threats
warned myanmar's military regime to
reverse course
urged iran to release dual national
prisoners and pledge to expand
covert 19 vaccine production the aim of
these meetings has been to present a
united front of like-minded democratic
countries
against authoritarian rivals if you're
worried about
uh what china does i think it's more
likely to need to rather react
in anger it's more likely going to need
to take a look in the mirror
and understand that it needs to take
into account this growing body of
opinion
that thinks these basic international
rules have got to be adhered to
the challenge for the g7 was finding a
common voice after the disruption of the
pandemic and the trump presidency
and they'll claim to have been
successful in doing so here critics
though will say the covert cases
show it was too early to try
face-to-face diplomacy again
and that has implications for plans to
bring heads of state together
in cornwall in june covid scares aside
the foreign ministers leave hoping
they've put the g7 and multilateral
diplomacy back on track
a month before returning to britain with
their leaders
dominic waghorn sky news lancaster house